we had another we had a couple calls
that came in a lot of
you know we put a question on the last
episode
about if you had a if you had to take a
man on a date
and this is no homo type of stuff this
is straight up just
straight this is if you if you're a
straight man but you had to take a man
on a date how would you do it
what would you do we had a couple
answers that came in
to the hotline nine eight five six six
four
nine five zero three let's hear one game
hey this is dusty from leesburg again i
was with him
what's up dusty and i've always valued
that type of name a name that also
you know kind of has an atmosphere to it
dusty stormy
you know windy oh there's windy you know
that [ __ ] will just scoot off in any
direction yeah
you know buzz i like that kind of name
oh buzz there's buzz
you know we've been hit by lightning you
know him
you know bugs love him all right let's
hear it more of the episode and
seen you wanted us to call in to tell
you what we where we'd take a guy on a
date what we would do
and look i want to also and now that i'm
hearing this back this sounds extremely
gay man which is fine if somebody's gay
that's fine
and if you want to be an adult gay male
then more power to you buddy i'll vote
for you okay
depending on what's going on and if
you're legitimate gang
i'm a straight man been married for
i hope my wife don't hear this i don't
know a little while now dude your wife
ain't listening to this damn
show man gang brother but i like your
attitude man gang
it's five six years somewhere and uh
i don't know where i would take any man
on a date but i'll pretend i'm just
taking me on a date
and in order to get to my heart you
would need okay
take me to a a nice steak restaurant
buy me that porterhouse oh damn bone in
tomahawk ribeye
dusty got that pricey tongue on him
onward dust
i need a medium with the outside chart
a little garlic butter on it maybe some
steak rolls if you got them
then after that all you need to do is
purchase me a bag of marijuana
and uh get me a couple cigars rolling
blizzies up with damn dust
so dusty's getting blunted
and that's the dude if you getting hit
hooked up on them giants dusty that's
that's risque man because that's risque
you know i remember when i was young
they had a kind of a strand of weed that
came through town
and a lot of people if they smoked it
they was doing kind of gay activity
you know they'd shake somebody you know
you know i'm i know my buddy roy smoked
it and he shook somebody's hand for
almost a minute
you know where you'd see somebody doing
a piggyback for no reason
you know i remember a couple buddies of
mine smoked a bag of it for the funeral
and they doing piggybacks over there
right right next to the dead
and that's i mean that's mildly
you know that's damn 40 percent g-a-y
baby
you know so it's just interesting when
you think about it
you know but that's i remember that
strand of wheat i don't remember what it
was called
but that's when that hit the scene
people
people were shook you know
wives were standing around in the yard
just holding their hand they didn't know
what was going on
because people was just puffing their
way right over onto each other's nuts
you know and nutting around on each
other's bodies and that kind of stuff
you know being gay um
and yeah sorry to have a lot of this
kind of talk on here but look this is
what the epis you know
we asked straight men if you were to
take a man
on a date how would you do it and i want
to tell you the number of
calls that came in
just blew my mind i mean we probably had
about
70 dates that got called in um
here we go right here and i think
getting it look man if you're gonna
that's brave of you dusty you're trying
to get bent out
you know you letting the man give you
that stake and then you try you let them
buy you a blunt
damn you a easy day dude damn
you a easy date bro you got to tighten
up
man gang man onward let's hear a call
what's up theo vaughn love the podcast
man this is gavin
calling from read oso new mexico the
lower 48 baby
amen brother praise god baby pg daddy
you know feliz christo
feliz christopher yeah that's what i
grew up with
my name is gavin earl my parents are
white if you can't tell
but on your last podcast you wanted to
see what
you do if you take a dude on a date no
homo [ __ ]
but my question is what song plays in
your head when you're getting [ __ ]
no homo mine's that lip from lint
biscuit
oh damn that's all see it's funny i
think there should probably be like
nothing else matters from metallica or
something
damn this this call took a wrong turn
bro you going
dude you just supposed to take the man
on a date buddy
gavin you know i respect you and
everything but you just there's nothing
that's wild man you going real deep bro
we trying to keep it
classy man a lot of people on this on on
you know a lot of us
you know have wives or hope to have a
wife one day
you know a lot of us still chasing that
little
you know that body wallet bro that
cooter
so that's too much for us man gang bro
be well
um what else man we'll take one more
one more call that came in man uh about
that
and uh and what people
what people thought was good here we go
this is adam from spartanburg south
carolina
what's up adam thank you for calling and
that's a biblical name
and that's a risky name too because
somebody died
who got killed at
the beginning of the bible
kane got killed
he murdered his brother so you know
keep tabs on your kiddos man because
that was adam's kids
so you got risky that's a damn brave
name dude adam
and uh but that's okay man you know that
could be part of the past man let's hear
more
uh i'll let you pause to do that what's
up adam thanks
um this is about that mandate
if you got a you know mandate for a
mandate
where would you go all straight no homo
gang bro if you down like that but
uh i think a perfect mandate would be
a little axe growing you know what i
mean get that with that bladed
hitter stand in line throw it out of
bull's eye
a tad bit you know romantic baby
a little scary a little uh a little fun
you know you ain't got a drink but maybe
whoever wants to get a little sip
get a little football you know what i
think step on with some blades
sounds dangerous i like that man i think
that's a nice thing
you know i think that's a nice thing and
sometimes i envision a world where
things could be like that
where a straight man could take a gay
man out to throw some maxes or you know
hum some blades or whatever
or do bow and arrows or whatever or
shoot down a hot air balloon whatever
you know spend time together without it
being sexual
or trying to be like that
but it's risky too a lot of gay men they
love that risk
you know it i mean dude that's a
i mean that's risky
i mean that's wild bro but amen man i
appreciate you calling in and giving us
that option dude and just seeing what's
on
seeing what's going on we got one more
that came in
what's up theo uh i got my dog over here
hacking on some parking jerky
this is joby from louisville kentucky
and i was just answering your question
uh
if i were a man but i am and i was
taking another man
out i'd probably take her him he she
20 20 i don't know that's [ __ ] with
me probably taking down the
triple x theater and uh
put on a good show and uh
watch some [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
because i'm not gay so how about that
he got a problem [ __ ] you gang gang buzz
buzz
amen brother now that's a way to do it
but you know that man is going to be
uncomfortable
if you got a man at least you know you
know
maybe draw some wiener on a notepad or
something and save it for him do
something don't just think about
yourself there
but also i think that could be fun you
know you take him out there and just
kind of you know have like a cr
you know for i think for a gay male
that's probably like going on a damn
roller coaster
taking him to a strip club you know let
him
you know home a couple dollars at a
cooter praise
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one